this is the Ingram angle who's on fire
and who's full of fury that's the focus
of tonight's angle if any Democratic
president had presided over the roaring
stock market two million new jobs
created in 2017 and robust GDP growth
that President Trump has presided over
the media would be churning out fawning
coverage of him and his entire economic
team reporters at the New York Times and
CNN oh my gosh they'd be interviewing
everyday Americans on the street who
would talk about how his policies were
making their lives so much better
a none foreign policy of what would they
be saying you'd be reading and hearing
daily about how other countries were
marveling at his bold transformative
approach to global affairs America
wasn't going to be taken for granted
or taken to the cleaners any longer by
allies or enemies yeah of course there's
no such luck for president Trump who
instead endures day after day of the
most sickening ly biased and overrated
coverage by pundits and DNC operatives
masquerading as journalists like a good
campaign operation this comical
commentariat coordinates their messaging
just as the president is hitting his
stride on judicial nominations tax
reform and forcing our rule of law
deregulation and trade they play the
only card they have personal attacks
this president is unstable and he
basically acts like a child inside the
White House and can't be controlled
we interviewed Trump half a dozen times
maybe a dozen more over the course of
the year and he would often tell the
same stories over and over again he both
has these issues of mental fitness and
then has these actual questions of
intellectual capacity this were the
leader of Germany or China or Brazil
what would we say we would say these are
the messages from a person who is not
well none of this normal none of this
acceptable
none of this frankly stable behavior now
the interesting question isn't why
they're doing this it's why aren't
Republicans responding to defend this
president with the same
coordinated and well orchestrated
communication strategy
one recent ray of hope in that regard
came before Christmas on the day all
those GOP members of Congress showed up
at the White House and together with the
president they celebrated the passage of
tax reform that image sent a powerful
signal of unity and support and it was
just the type of organized unified front
that we need as we kick off the new year
with a lot of new challenges I think we
should let the American people see an
optimistic determined focused GOP and
White House working together seamlessly
and I'm talking about on the issues
Trump ran on issues like border
enforcement the wall trade reducing the
size of government we do not need a
thousand different voices talking at
cross-purposes on the core goals of the
Trump agenda that were so popular that
drove him to office and as for defending
against the slippery toads who sit
around catching while others do the hard
work of governing all I'll say is this
consider the sources and how
spectacularly wrong they've been in
there supposed area of expertise Donald
Trump will not be the Republican nominee
and almost almost all certainty the
others that he will not be President
that's a guy who knows he's going to
lose I don't know that he's ever wanted
to win but it's just it's it's sad I
thought about eight weeks ago or so that
she could not win simply by being not
Trump turns out no not really
it's not Trump and she's gonna be Prezi
United States with a fairly significant
electoral margin this is not funny this
is really bad just for the record we're
all really nervous so if people out
there feel nervous we do too we don't
think this is funny actually I think
their over-the-top histrionic episodes
of faulty and emotional predictions are
absolutely hilarious this is all they
got Trump's policies are working they
know they're working the country is
working and they claim Trump is out of
touch and disengaged
no he's not but maybe it's time to look
the mirror kids now unlike so many who
never saw the Trump jugger not coming I
did and I support the conservative
populist agenda he ran on but at the
same time I'll continue to be candid
about the pitfalls and problems this
administration faces and I'll continue
to point out not just the successes but
the missteps
everybody makes missteps and missed
opportunities as I did last night
look no White House staffer should have
ever been encouraged to speak with a
muckraker like Michael Wolfe how did he
have access to the White House think
about this guy his book is replete with
errors and unsubstantiated rumors bad or
no sourcing and it contains lines that
people may or may not have said hey but
don't take my word for it
former Obama autos are Steve Rattner
wrote in a tweet van and may well have
said all that stuff but let's remember
that wolf is an unprincipled writer of
fiction than Maggie Haberman of the New
York Times offered this insight he
creates a narrative that is notionally
true that conceptually true the details
are often wrong and I can I can see
several places in the book that are
wrong he gets basic details wrong he has
a history of telling people they're
off-the-record
and in disregarding right now wait a
second and Wolfe is the man and the work
that he he even put in this book is what
the left has pinned all their hopes and
dreams up for taking down Trump he
couldn't luck with that this is nothing
but a left-wing la-la-land stuff Wolfe
is a type of author who traffics in
broad generalities and poisonous
unsubstantiated facts mr. president your
political instincts are terrific
remember spit balls off a battleship
that means you're at the battleship keep
your eye on the prize the prize is the
American people Wolfe's lurid tall tales
and embellished quotes I'm gonna negate
the election or that could stop your
progress on behalf of the American
people in fact Gallup remember this
reported this week that the end of
December the president's approval rating
was up to its highest level in six
President Trump has had a really good
year all things considered and he's
poised to have an even better 2018 that
means the country is gonna have a better
year in fact the president seems to have
all the fire and the only fury I see is
coming from the media who hate to cover
it and that's the angle